your view on the Second Amendment and
why you are pro-second Amendment the
reason I'm impressed
I'm protection of all of us to the
federal government I don't think that
they have the wisdom I don't think that
they have the mental wherewithal to
decide that sort of thing Sean yeah and
so I would take almost the exact
opposite point is that one of the
primary goals of government is to defend
ourselves that's like one of the is to
protect the American citizens is to
protect us from each other is to make
let me yeah but it's to protect the
American citizens from foreign and
domestic enemies and it's to keep us
safe and that is one of the primary
goals of the US government and so I
think that anything that we can show
that can tangibly decrease the amount of
violence and tangibly save lives should
be implemented because that's what the
founding foreigners fathers wanted is a
constitution that changes with the times
and adapts to what is best for the
people of this country